I'm pleased to say we're joined now by
the minister for food Mark Spencer Mark
good morning to you thanks very much for
coming I should pick up on what we've
seen there in Brazil I mean obviously
you in the environment department so you
must be delighted that a man who's come
in in Brazil so it's going to protect
the Amazon River yeah I think I think
that's huge progress isn't it and I
think uh it's great news to see
democracy happening all around the world
yeah and it's a huge combat for a man as
well a leftist though I suppose well but
you know I think the environment is a
big issue and Brazil is going to be a
big player in that and I think this is
good news for Brazil it's good news for
the world okay let's move on to some
domestic issues and we've got to talk
about what's happening down in Kent at
the moment Mark I mean you got an
Immigration Center there that's causing
4 000 people capacity for 1600. what's
going on down there I mean there are
huge challenges here you know I think uh
clearly we've got to break the model
that is bringing destitute people across
the channel there are some very bad
people who are putting innocent people's
lives at risk we have to break that
model uh of course when they get here
we've got to try and find a way of
dealing with them passionately and and
looking after them and processing them
as quickly as possible and there are
competing Ambitions to try and get
people processed but also to look after
them and and keep them safe but we're
not keeping them safe because they're
coming under attack here in this
um Center and not only that the center's
got diphtheria diphtheria and MRSA yeah
so we're working very hard to try and
resolve those challenges there is a
scheme that pushes people out into local
authorities to support them in in hotels
which were uh which we're we're working
towards with working with local
authorities but as you say there are
huge challenges but the answer to this
is to break the model that is delivering
these people to our to our doors to our
Shores and that's what we're working
very hard to to try and do we'll come
until you're breaking that model but you
say you're going to move them out into
hotels it's exact opposite of what the
current Home Secretary so so we're
working with local authorities to house
I'm sorry uh we're we're so basically
we're working those authorities to house
them locally there's a scheme I think
it's time 20 million pounds we've
invested in that scheme to support
people but the answer is of course to
process them quickly where they where
they are so why did the Home Secretary
then stop people moving out into hotels
during her her first tenure before she
she stepped away again
um she had put the block on hotel rooms
being used why was that because she
wants to process them quickly you know
we've got to try and make sure that
those who are genuine Asylum Seekers and
there are safe routes of course to to
get here via a a safe system she wants
to process them very quickly and work
out who we need to help protect and who
we need to return but you can't process
them if they're in these squalid
conditions can you because it's not
getting anywhere there's a huge Log Jam
there isn't there so there are a lot of
people coming and we need to break that
model we need to make sure that we stop
these people coming across the channel
that's what we're working to do it's
been described as awful inhumane I mean
you can't be proud clearly we have an
obligation to look after these people
and to support them and to keep them
safe and there are huge challenges I I
acknowledge that
um we've got to try and deal with these
people compassionately and quickly I'm
glad you've acknowledged that because
looking at your record voting on
immigration it's it's quite a hard line
mark would you would you say that's a
fair way of describing it so I I think
we've got to make sure we control our
own borders that's what um people voted
for we want to make sure that the people
who are coming are are genuine uh
refugees and we've actually got a really
good track record you know looking at
all the people we've taken from
Afghanistan from Syria from Hong Kong
the UK has a very proud record of of
taking people from other countries who
are in Desperate situations I I you know
that will continue absolutely we need to
make sure that we're getting the right
people we should be pleased with that
but I'm saying specifically on on voting
to to stop people who've been here for
six months finding work if their
processes and haven't been put through
yet there's been some vote some
decisions made that have been made it
very difficult for people who come to
this country and I and I put it to you
now that that system is completely
failed that idea of that of lacking in
compassion for some of these people who
are coming here has broken down because
we have 38 000 come down I mean as I say
we've got a huge track record of taking
people from other parts of the world you
know I mean just look at the you're
creating the amount of people we've
taken from Ukraine that we should be
very proud of that record but those who
are coming we need to process as quickly
as possible to work out who is a genuine
Asylum seeker and and who could be
returned to a safe country that they
came from what about building uh new
areas to hold the new new centers well I
mean these things are all under uh
review constantly of course that that is
a huge Challenge and that's what we're
uh that's what we're seeking to do to
solve that challenge as quickly as
possible I mean you've caused it you've
challenged many many times the only
solution is what to tackle the business
model well that's part of the solution
of course that the other solution is to
uh is the Rwanda option to send people
to a safe country like Rwanda well we're
still working our way through that there
are a number of legal challenges to that
um but ultimately you've got to get to
these very bad people who are putting
lives in danger by putting them on a an
unsea-worthy Craft on the other side of
the channel and sending them across
people you know putting their lives in
danger we have to break that model we
have an obligation to try and stop that
isn't the fact the case that after years
of of aggressive rhetorical towards
migration uh migrants we haven't got to
a system that's fit for purpose at this
stage and now we're seeing thousands of
people coming across we're seeing
tensions in in local towns I mean
there's a fire bombing at one of the
centers yesterday Market yeah and that's
that is currently under an investigation
so I don't want to say too much about
that but we've been able to move some
people away from that incident in in
Dover but that's an ongoing
investigation but do you accept that
some of the rhetoric around the way that
we treat migrants coming to this country
has has not been helpful and has led to
some of those increased tensions no no I
think I mean clearly as I keep saying
that it is a huge challenge that these
people are wanting to come across the
channel to the United Kingdom uh it is
the the bad people in this are the
people who are exploiting those
individuals they are taking their life
savings they are putting them on an
unseaworthy vessel and putting their
lives in danger we have an obligation to
try and stop that from happening and
stop these people from drowning in the
channel is the right homosexual to deal
with this yeah in the prime minister's
uh reappointed her
um she's put out comes up and said that
she made a mistake I think we need to
give her the space to get on and do it I
mean it was a mistake it wasn't
Anonymous honest mistake there was some
of the reporting well you know I think
you know often you have politicians on
here and you accuse them of never
apologizing and never saying sorry she
made a mistake she put her hands up and
said I'm so sorry I made a mistake uh
the Prime Minister has reappointed her
and I think she needs to concentrate now
on getting on with her her job you know
she's recruiting police officers driving
down crime concentrating on burglaries
and dealing with this this challenge of
migrants crossing the channel I mean
can't you concentrate with all of these
noises she's not just about mistake is
there are there's reporting there have
been many mistakes and there's also
reporting that those within her
Department are not happy with her she's
completely focused on the job we need to
get let her get on to it you've got full
she's got your full fullback of course
let's talk about um what happened with
the former prime minister former
secretary this trust his phone was
hacked it's been reported in the
newspapers recently
um I mean you're in government do you
use your government phone for any
personal business I do not no but I mean
you say you do get quite a lot of
briefing
um from the security services on what to
do and what not to do
um so you know it's quite important to
get that right I don't want to comment
too much on it because of course what I
don't want to do is is tell the world
exactly what that briefing says but you
do get a lot of support when you become
a government Minister on what is
appropriate and inappropriate as a as a
government so perhaps she wasn't
listening to The Briefing then if she
was using it well you know I think you
know as you said she made a mistake but
uh well this trust made a mistake as
well no sorry I thought you're talking
about the Home Secretary
the former prime minister clearly was
hacked you know so that is the first
thing you do is say oh my goodness I've
been hacked help and the security
service will help you with that with
that challenge now of course you don't
always know which is why you've got to
be super careful I think the concern was
that she was perhaps talking on a
personal phone and there may be some
stuff in there that leaves are open to
be called well we all talk on personal
phones don't we you know I ring my wife
maybe there's some little man in China
listening to the conversations between
me and my wife but uh you know you've
just got to be careful about what
information you use on which on which
phone and you get a lot of help and
support from the security services on
that I do think it's time for some more
help and support for some of these
ministers as well being as careful with
security it is it is ongoing I mean we
need to recognize you know there are
states out there that want to do us harm
and uh you know Russia's being very
aggressive in in Ukraine there are lots
of people that want to do this country
harm which is why we have to be careful
give us a little bit about cop27 the
Prime Minister said that he wasn't going
to go out to focus on domestic
commitments it's now being reported he
may well go what's changed well I think
the Prime Minister has a huge inbox you
know he's come into office he's got an
inbox which is full to the brim clearly
he wants to concentrate on the financial
statement and uh that's what he's doing
but if he's able to get through all of
that you know cop is very important it's
very important to the to the government
it's important to our future uh you know
and so we'll send out senior ministers
but that's yet to be decided who's going
to go would you like to see him go well
if he's got time and only he will know
what he's got in his inbox and in his
diary If he if he has the time but he'll
make that call and uh I'm sure it'll be
the right one would be best to have the
Prime Minister there on the world stage
he first chance it's not just copies it
as well Mark is it he's going to get to
meet other world leaders there it's his
first chance we've got a war in Europe
well as a former Chancellor he's met
lots of those uh world leaders in in the
past but it is an important topic to the
government and we will send a serious
team out there just lastly before you go
because last time I spoke to you I did
ask you about this and we didn't get uh
any conclusion on it Mr Gandhi the
investigation into what happened with
her it was uh kicked off in his long
grass when the ethics commissioner
resigned where are we with that now so
the honest truth is I don't know I'm
waiting for that report to come out
obviously we've had quite a lot of
turmoil in the system my understanding
is that Lord geick was very close to
coming forward I'm absolutely
desperately you said the same thing I
know I know it is very very very
frustrating for me to be honest because
obviously I know I'm completely honest
and I just want them to come forward
with that report and say there we go so
you are expecting it still to come come
forward well
all right